foreign
is with us Clarence is in Baton Rouge
hey Clarence what's up
Hey Dean Rachel it's really good to talk
to you and Rachel I have to say that
this week's episode of smart money happy
hour actually endured more than I
thought I would yes thank you Clarence
you're saving me wow you're so Clarence
your love is blind guy
I wasn't until I listened to it and
Rachel was so enthusiastic oh she is
enthusiastic you gotta binge it over
Christmas break you just have to be
careful what you're enthusiastic about
out there I'm just saying all right man
how can we help today
sure so um uh you know it's almost
Christmas time and uh we're on baby step
two but my parents said they wanted to
uh pay for the gas money for us to come
home for Christmas because obviously
that wasn't an option
um for us to come home while we're in
baby step two and you know there's no
strings attached they don't want us to
get any gifts or anything they just want
us to be home for the holidays with them
uh you know especially they want to see
their grandkids and everything so
um I just wanted to hear your advice
about it because I just feel guilty
because I have been you know working the
baby steps getting stuff done but I just
feel like everything's you know my fault
because you know I'm the one that got us
into the debt to begin with and my
parents have helped us out with things
before with you know especially before
we were he's all intense and now that we
are it just kind of feels weird you know
accepting their uh charity when you know
I just want to kind of just do things
and just kind of Buckle in myself and
just get through the baby stuff
okay so I kind of want to figure out is
this a
um
a little bit of just like a pride thing
or is there a value system that you and
your wife have set this holiday season
and the only reason I asked is I was
talking to Dr John Loney about this and
about you know setting up boundaries and
like if things are just if they're crazy
like there's a level that you you know
may say no this year
um not necessarily because you can't
financially afford it but just even on
an emotional standpoint of like if
you're just like I just want our
families choosing something different so
is there any level of that or is it just
strictly you feel weird accepting money
from your parents for for gas money but
you guys want to go there
well I I think you uh nailed exactly
what my wife has been saying that she
doesn't want to be a prizing for me of
being just self-reliant
um uh it's more of just like you know
we've been you know working hard towards
it's not like it's gonna negatively
contribute to us it's not going to put
us any further in debt I just you know
my parents have done a lot to help us
over the years and sometimes it feels
weird for me being you know in my late
20s and you know I'm working on you know
various degrees so we're not making a
ton of money right now but
um you know eventually we'll you know
build up our income but it just just
feels like uh I I guess that's why I was
asking to see if it was a pride thing
for me as opposed to just a hey Mrs you
know it is a pride thing and it's not a
bad kind of pride
to just stand up and go you know I I
feel more like a little boy than a man
when I do this and it I don't like it
and that's okay to say out loud okay and
then the weird thing is once you say it
out loud it kind of loses its power
um and so like um you know we were
making uh pretty decent money we didn't
need the money and when Rachel was a
little girl her Grandpa uh Sharon's dad
owned a gas station
and it was kind of tradition when you
went in for Thanksgiving everybody
filled up at the gas station and it
wasn't you know he's like make sure you
get a tank of gas before you leave more
like you bet Peppa
especially the cost of gas right now you
know so uh but I I and but it didn't
have it wasn't because we couldn't
afford it that was different or it
wasn't because we were working a plan
that was different but it was still free
money from Grandpa you know kind of
thing uh so I kind of get what you're
saying I think it's a normal feeling to
do this but if I were in your shoes I I
would uh accept the gift and go home and
let them see their grandkids
okay well that's great that's exactly
why I called you guys I think that you
and uh Rachel uh perfect ones to answer
this so thank you so much it speaks
highly of your character that you're
struggling with this a little bit
if you let it completely dominate who
you are and keep everyone from having a
good Christmas then it's kind of gone
over the bubble does that make sense
yes it does yeah so I'm proud of you
yeah yep accept it go home for the
holidays yeah that's great